foreign
[Music]
governance my name is Irina farbuck and
I'm one of the product leaders for our
Google smart analytics portfolio and
joining me today is Ben clinch the
principal Enterprise architect for data
governance at BT
today we're going to have a lively
discussion talking about the top
strategies to help youth governance as
an engine and an enabler for Innovation
across the Enterprise
as many of us are aware Enterprise data
is distributed across data warehouses
data Lakes data Marts databases and the
pace of connect how the data is
distributed is only accelerated
the challenge is that as you distribute
your data in each of these systems comes
with its own way to manage metadata
governance policies but at the same time
your users are adopting more and more
tools and there's lots of innovation
there and so many teams are spending
countless hours moving data around
duplicating data and constantly building
the operational glue to make the data
available to the right users and their
tools of choice
the problem is these processes become
outdated almost the moment they get put
in your two choices are either undermine
governance or stifle Innovation and we
don't believe that that is a choice you
really have to face and we hope that we
can do better both from a technology but
also from an overall approach
perspective
but before we delve into governance it's
not a one point solution in fact it's a
combination of Technology people and
processes
here at Google we're focused on giving
you the technology so you can enable
your people and build the right
processes to help Drive innovation
without compromising governance for your
data I'll talk a little bit about the
technology piece and then Ben and I will
have a great conversation of how to
bring those three together to help you
innovate
so as many of you are aware last year we
introduced Google Cloud dataplex which
is our intelligent data fabric think of
it as a centralized layer to manage and
govern your distributed data there are a
number of key foundational things around
centralizing the metadata for all of
your distributed data State centralized
policy and security and governance as
well as data intelligence that underpins
everything we do to really help you
build that end-to-end life cycle
anchored in active metadata from
discovering your data to organizing it
in a way that makes sense to your
business to then managing and governing
and making sure that your users can
trust their data how many times have all
of us been in a meeting where we say
well that number doesn't make sense so I
don't trust anything that's presented
here we want to make sure that we help
you build the trust in the data so your
organization can succeed
there are a couple of core principles
that we feel are foundational to enable
that governance vision and something
that we hold very close and dear to
ourselves as we build dataplex
one of them is logical organization of
data think of it as a way to organize
your data in a way that makes sense for
your business
irrespective of whether that's
physically stored so if you have your
customer data or HR data or regionally
you can organize and govern and manage
that data align to the business breaking
down those storage barriers
the second thing is what we call
attribute-based policies think of that
as assigning meaning to your data and
business intent so if I have my
sensitive customer data or if I have
regulations that are coming in I can
codify it through this attribute-based
approach then apply policies at that
level
and last but definitely not the least is
the open and extensible approach we
don't intend to be the only layer or the
only system in your environment we want
you to take advantage of other systems
that you have across your ecosystem and
also Plug and Play The Innovation that
your teams have built in certain areas
into this overall governance approach
and that's foundational to everything
with you
for many of our customers as they think
about governance they're embarking on
the speed of mesh architecture to really
centralize a few key best practices
through the centralized governance teams
and then enabling the individual teams
within their organizations to treat data
as product and really innovate and share
across the organizations
again we are there to provide the tools
and really help you define your own
vision and your own strategy of what you
want to bring to life
at next we have a number of exciting
Innovations for dataplex
we're not covering those in this session
but we have a detailed session that's
covering all of these announcements in
depth that's linked here
and at this stage I would love to
welcome Ben to the virtual stage welcome
Ben and thank you so much for joining
and could you please share a little bit
more with the audience about your role
and what you do at BT and broader in the
industry thank you Arena it's a pleasure
to be talking with you
at BT I'm the principal Enterprise
architect for data governance and
information architecture which means
that I own the vision for data Fabric
and how we manage data across BT's
considerable estate
most recently I've been contributing to
the EDM Council alongside Google
to the cloud data management
capabilities which is a new framework
for ensuring that data is managed well
at scale in the cloud
that's incredible and we really
appreciate the partnership there I also
hear that you have a pretty unique role
here at Boutique can you tell us a
little bit more about that yes so I was
really excited to hear about this
opportunity at BT I joined 10 months ago
and um BT had the vision of bringing
data management and data architecture
um and architecture in general together
to ensure that um everything that we did
was scalable and well supported by
technology
that's incredible I'm sure a lot of
people listening to us are kind of
struggling still to understand like what
is data management and governance so how
do you can you please help us Define
that and how you think about it
fantastic so data management is the
practice of of managing down the risk
and and managing up the value of data
across an organization's estate and data
governance
is is the means of overseeing that data
in terms of ownership and ensuring that
it is well controlled
um there are a number of other terms
that I think are incredibly helpful in
this space a new earlier mentioned data
mesh in terms of organizing your data
and your culture in a way that can be
ownable and data fabric which we'll talk
a little bit more about I guess I think
both of these phrases are extremely
exciting in the way that they're
bringing together business architecture
which gives the context a business
strategy and the value and the
motivation of an organization in terms
of how it wants to manage its data data
management the profession and practice
of managing that data is mentioned just
now and then data architecture the way
that we organize our systems structures
and data flows and Technologies to
support that that enable you to be able
to deliver that vision
so basically buzzwords aside these
brothers are bringing together a shift
in the convergence of these this
different disciplines that hopefully
help us better innovate for the future
and So speaking just a little bit of the
buzzword of how what is your view on the
data Fabric and beachy's Broad approach
to the data fabric term and the concept
if you will
so I in data fabric is an emotive term
in that it's it's being used in in a lot
of different contexts
um from our perspective we've defined it
as smart automated data management at
scale
so to be able to do smart automation is
something you have to have an
understanding of what it is you're
automating and so it's really important
that an organization develops a data
management data governance culture and
is organizing the way that it describes
its data and its intent around data in a
way that can be automated from a smart
perspective we're thinking in terms of
semantic meaning of data organized
around an information model that is
often a formal ontology like a knowledge
graph that allows that to be machine
readable across an organization it also
allows active metadata as you mentioned
earlier to be able to semantically
discover the data and record that
centrally so that you can then
understand the nature of the data and
how it should be treated to be able to
fulfill the organization's aims and then
from a scale perspective anything is
above a petabyte it requires a level of
automation to be able to achieve that
previously organizations at a smaller
scale would be able to throw bodies out
problems and try and manually manage
that data and and that does work for a
period for small organizations but if
you want to manage data for Value you
need to think beyond the compliance and
data and Regulatory data and to data
across the estate that's going to
provide better customer experience
and one point really that I always try
and stress is that data fabric is about
smart automation the data management
itself is not optional so if you're not
smartly automating it
you still need to be managing the data
manually and that can be quite expensive
at scale
no that's such a valid point there's no
magic button and it doesn't make kind of
the hard work of data management go away
it just helps automate and scale it so
how do you think about what are the key
steps in designing data governance
strategy and architecture
fantastic well the first thing is to
begin with the end in mind so um we
always say have a data strategy have an
understanding of the value that you want
to create out of that data and the the
data risk that you want to control now
that that means that you need to be well
informed about the Regulatory and legal
environment that your organization
operates Within
and then you need to determine do you
want to go for the defensive data
management which is effectively managing
that risk which a lot of organizations
start solely with or do you want to have
a blend of of the value that you want to
create out of out of that data alongside
managing down that risk that will inform
a roadmap of value and risk that you
want to be able to deliver over a period
of time
then Baseline your organization
it's really important to be able to
quantify
objectively where your organization is
in its data management maturity and
um one of the best ways of doing that is
using the data management capability
assessment methodology also at the EDM
Council which allows you to be able to
say we've got these things in place we
haven't got these things in place yet
and and then you can objectively move
forward along a roadmap and measure
yourself as an organization against your
industry
we have a saying at BT about winning
with tech and
um when you're going along that journey
of maturity of the data capabilities
you need to be thinking in terms of how
how are we going to be able to implement
embed this and automate it and so design
it from the ground up in a way that
allows you to be able to scale
that means one ensuring that your data
management policies have been described
logically and in a structure like if
this then that and can be propagated
across an organization
and then secondly ensure that you have
the technology to be able to propagate
and benefit from that information
information across uh The Firm
and then finally it's it's very
important to be able to reward the
people within your organization to
create the data value
so if you have one system or an
organization that's creating a certain
valuable data set as you described
around the domains earlier and they are
being used by many different systems and
processes Downstream to create value for
your customers and and make your your
business more efficient every Buck you
spend and invest in that data and the
team that are and the technologies that
are organizing that benefits a multitude
of Downstream
um teams and processes
and then finally keep going
um it takes sizeable organization two to
three years to be able to reach data
management and maturity and so ensure
that you're measuring your progress at
each point and and demonstrating real
movement in terms of data management
maturity but recognize that it is often
for organization a multi-year journey
that's incredible and I love the people
aspect of this that really rewarding
people for doing the right thing for the
Innovation and value that they create
what resonates with you about Google's
approach to data governance and how do
you think about that
well it's no coincidence that
um uh the the things that I've been
describing are very aligned to to the
the the excellent uh description that
you gave earlier of how how Google is
moving forward in the space
um we were both at the EDM Council and I
was really enthused at what Google
contributed there but also how receptive
Google was to
um the needs of the various different
customers who are also contributing so I
would I would say the partnership with
Google in terms of a shared
understanding and vision of what we want
to achieve with data and data management
is very powerful aspect the other part
is that there obviously are a large
number of really powerful tools already
within uh gcp's offering and the the
road map that you're setting out to to
enhance those
um progressively is is really powerful
as well and being able to
understand how Google is moving forward
in this very Dynamic space allows us to
be able to plan ahead and and
um achieve a vision through
that partnership
that's a wonderful and thank you Ben so
much for your partnership and your
guidance to some of these things
um last maybe one bit of nugget what
would you leave other data Leaders with
as they are starting on their data
governance Journey
great well there's a an ancient Chinese
phrase
um that says that the the best time to
have planted a tree is 20 years ago and
the next best time is now so I would say
um to those people who are thinking
about going on that data management
Journey
start it and
um follow those steps that we mentioned
earlier and keep going because each step
can can create that value for you and it
becomes cumulative
well I just have to say thank you so
much ben thank you for sharing your
strategy and vision and your advice to
others in the audience I hope everybody
enjoyed and learned quite a bit from
this conversation and I hope you enjoyed
the rest of the show and please continue
the conversation with us online thank
you so much
[Music]